evil is lurking in the dark places of
this world it's hiding in our homes
where we sleep these are the true tales
of war as told by those who we've been
taught we thought we'd found the house
of our dreams like the house of our
dreams little do they know the horror
that I lingered within looking back the
warning signs were there I just didn't
want to see them I mean the house is so
cheap you don't understand this house is
cheap because it's haunted I'm making a
hasty decision it's not safe for your
children says negligence would not go
unpunished strange things started
happening right away I remember going to
the bathroom one night
I haven't brushed my teeth in years off
to the bathroom
Fawcett's was pouring blood blood pure
blood I just didn't I didn't touch my
face the next day Ted bumbles for a way
to explain what he saw the night before
Lee
um there's okay so hair isn't here that
happened there
ha ha huh yeah I got the feeling my wife
didn't believe me right away it wasn't
really anything she said there was just
kind of a tone in her voice the faucet
was spouting bloodless [__] but none
of that happened I told her about it and
and she kind of comforted me but there
wasn't slapping or cursing you're a
shitstorm of lies Ted you're full of
steamy [__] I just said no cursing the
following notes ted claims more stuff
that it probably did have happen that
night i saw a ghost
it was very real and very terrifying she
dressed as a Puritan and she had him she
had an axe
that's a Boston Terrier being held by a
black man that's not even close to what
I said I'm afraid of black people I am
Not Afraid you peed your pants again
you're constantly peeing your pants
listen also I'm a racist what also you
can't achieve an erection that's true
okay you know what forget this what
happened to me was real and terrifying
and it doesn't deserve to be mocked
oh I'm peeing my pants